Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we have two extremely hard problems
on the menu.
One is facial alignment and the other is 3D
facial reconstruction.
For both problems, we have an image as an
input, and the output should be either a few
lines that mark the orientation of the jawline,
mouth and eyes, and in the other case, we
are looking for a full 3D computer model of
the face.
And all this should happen automatically,
without any user intervention.
This is extremely difficult, because this
means that we need an algorithm that takes
a 2D image, and somehow captures 3D information
from this 2D projection, much like a human
would.
This all sounds great and would be super useful
in creating 3D avatars for Skype calls, or
scanning real humans to place them in digital
media such as feature movies and games.
That would be amazing, but, is this really
possible?
This work uses a convolutional neural network
to accomplish this, and it not only provides
high-quality outputs, but it creates them
in less than 10 milliseconds per image, which
means that it can process a hundred of them
every second.
That is great news indeed, because it also
means that doing this for video in real time
is also a possibility!
But not so fast, because if we are talking
about video, new requirements arise.
For instance, it is important that such a
technique is resilient against changes in
lighting.
This means that if we have different lighting
conditions, the output geometry the algorithm
gives us shouldn't be wildly different.
The same applies to camera and pose as well.
This algorithm is resilient against all three,
and it has some additional goodies.
For instance, it finds the eyes properly through
glasses, and can deal with cases where the
jawline is occluded by the hair, or infer
its shape when one side is not visible at
all.
One of the key ideas is to give additional
instruction to the convolutional neural network
to focus more of its efforts to reconstruct
the central region of the face because that
region contains more discriminative features.
The paper also contains a study that details
the performance of this algorithm.
It reveals that it is not only five to eight
times faster than the competition, but also
provides higher quality solutions.
Since these are likely to be deployed in real-world
applications very soon, it is a good time
to start brainstorming about possible applications
for this.
If you have ideas beyond the animation movies
and games line, let me know in the comments
section.
I will put the best ones in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!